[Applause]
that's an excellent song that's a cool
song I come over here and Andy was
singing that song is going way down now
way down now I was doing a lot better
than that but I'm not gonna tell them
how I was doing oh come on do it it's
not good enough to be done in public oh
I think your singing is very calm way
down now yeah he was a lounge singer
when I found this guy people don't know
that about Andy yeah grilling in a men's
lounge handing out singing numbers they
don't have to know everything
misty is the best policy are you Jeff
you know summer's over September's here
yeah you happen about the love autumn
yeah really do it it's beautiful you're
an autumnal kind of Bounce right well
and also because I sweat less yeah my
way was so much more poetic well the
point is you know September's here and
for you know a chunk of our audience
that means back to school so actually
Mandy and I had an idea we thought it
would be a nice gesture if we went and
visited some college freshmen and helped
them get acclimated to college life what
that's exactly right because both you
and I went to college mm-hmm you
graduated I didn't but we both know how
difficult it is to be a freshman so we
thought we'd we bring the kids some
gifts you know just get them acclimated
let them feel a little more at home
exactamundo right we brought a crew with
some surprises up to Marist College in
Poughkeepsie New York and we paid a
surprise visit to some of their dorms
and we just wanted to get them started
off on the right foot we thought it was
a really nice thing to do check it out
see if you agree all right basically
here's the idea Andy and I have brought
our college acclimation team that we got
our guys right out here guys come on in
here we got some great stuff it's gonna
really help you adjust to college here
we go right here look at this just you
know some munchies stuff yes there is a
God
this is gonna make your own accord
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sitting here with Tamla barber very cool
and you just as this year what are you a
freshman I'm a freshman it's my second
day second day how's it going so far
it's good it's good lots of fun
that NARS come on you can be honest with
us that sucks homesick here yeah why
don't you just let it all out it's the
only way to get rid of it I hate it
where is home for you sauce in New York
yeah okay we're putting you in a van and
we're taking you back right now you're
gonna work at the local dry goods store
at home okay that's good
I mean who needs an education thank you
that's what we want to get out there to
the kids are you here to study um this
management business management that's
not what you want to study there is it
no what do you want to study six a sex
ed my parents won't let you know who's
your dad deal his lawyer is he a really
tough lawyer kind of does he have a
paneled study and he wants to talk to
this he say son see me in the study yeah
and when he calls you son do you think
that it may be because he doesn't know
your name say he was said to your dad
dad a little space have you ever said
old man you're choking me know that
you're a potential suicide
we found the president's itinerary in
your desk what's that all about
I'm not gonna say anything okay you're a
very strange man you know that well
there's one thing that I think could
really help you acclimate better to
college a certain skill that I think
you're gonna need to know now this is a
virus Barbasol shaving cream this is a
church key can opener when you take the
pierce point this is gonna get your
aggression out
come in somebody's in the shower it
doesn't really matter who tear the
curtain back hook the church key on pop
the bottom the idea is to sneak into
here into the shower room with Barbasol
and a church key can opener now what you
do is when someone in the shower this
will help you work out some of that
aggression someone's in the shower you
pull it back you take the Pierce point
I'm trying to you know some of the
freshmen cos Angie and I when we were
freshmen in college no one made the
effort it was very scarring so here we
go we've got a can nature's finest
artichoke are you like this welcome or
how about some jumbo ripe olives jumbo
ripe olives Oh God let's get these in
here you you guys like this is good felt
the fish right here and that's in a gel
broth when you hang on
it'll be so stun when you push the
curtain back that they'll stand there
for all that weight see we've got some
stuff basically yeah that we are
bringing two college students to make
their lives a little better we got some
gefilte fish
cheese sauce that's hose right there
some fancy mint filling this is a this
is a lamp that Andy made named ray Lampe
just so it no one feels left out yeah
there's another let's get that stuff in
here we're on a tight schedule okay
there's more hose right here this is
pathetic a popcorn eat that and look
happy come on there you go that's a
king-sized mattress right here we're
just gonna jam that on your bed okay
come on guys let's go we'll just leave
that somewhere here okay
popcorn machine for you here and that
great have some popcorn while you're at
it yeah here you have some popcorn here
I'm just gonna put the snake here yeah
we'll just put the snake there on and we
really got to run but thanks very much a
lot and we hope you guys have a nice and
just speed this thing it needs a live
rabbit once every hour okay gotta go see
you ladies later watch this step back
real look at that so you get some real
distance out of it that way we give you
this Led Zeppelin poster
[Music]
so Tom while we're yet in the next can
ready is there anybody that you've met
you only been here a day but is there
anyone you've met so far that really
kind of ticked you off
I'm far away let's go Thomas is your
truth of your day scope
[Applause]
let me talk to you seriously for a
second has a guy ever tried that on
you've done this thing yeah never try
that okay cuz if someone does do that to
you give me a call and I'll come up here
I'll teach him a lesson all right that's
what I did if you can hook me up and
even be better you know hook you up
you wanna get hooked up yes it'd be
great what kind of guy are you looking
for um a romantic guy someone smart and
romantic
okay well we'll be around all day trying
to find someone if we find someone can I
send them back to you that's 512 room
512 512 okay are you in a hurry or
anything back there all these fees work
for that talking to us and everything so
close yeah so we decided to go someplace
where we knew we wouldn't bump into any
students the library did you like that
joke
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
later they hooked up for Tom everyone
feels bad for it now well that's what he
gets for playing along with our crap
alright we're gonna take a break and if
he's still here james carville is going
to talk to us
stick around we'll see you angel